[Music]
Lady Gaga's been a plague to buy Madonna
comparisons for years it feels uh
reductive is that good look it up but
now she's shutting him down on beats at
one Radio Madonna and I are very
different
hmm just saying just saying I play a lot
of instruments I write all my own music
I spent hours and hours a day in the
studio I'm a producer I'm a writer
you know there are major differences
between me and her and I don't mean that
in a disrespectful way it was absolutely
entitled to study yo I just will not be
compared to anyone anymore I am who the
I am and this is me that interview came
just before Gaga dropped her latest
studio album Joanne
[Music]
the star celebrated the launch of the
record Thursday night alongside RuPaul's
Drag Race all-stars 2 champ Alaska who
was dressed in her best Gaga drag hey
girl
we're just here being regular girl are
you a regular girl we're just right
Alaska is also the queen who showed up
to the VMAs as Britney Spears earlier
this year I feel great I'm really
excited
it's like glory it's time for glory you
know what I mean